le groupe démocrate s'associe au soutien
au maire de Saint-Brevin et à tous les
élus de la République mais le groupe
démocrate est choqué que certains soient
restés assis nous sommes scandalisés
le vent nous
aujourd'hui les extrêmes sortent de
l'ombre des complexés espérant que la
République se meurt et que leur violence
est une solution
le fleuve de notre détermination
républicaine et démocratique ne peut se
tarir face à des minorités qui n'ont que
les armes de la peur et du mensonge pour
exister
n'oublions pas notre histoire la
République est un combat et nos droits
des victoires
cette violence assumée débridé qui mena
l'aise qui menacent les élus nos
institutions et qui tabassent hier un
simple citoyen ne doit pas devenir la
norme et supplanter les véritables
actions citoyennes notre notre jeunesse
s'engage elle fête son quotidien combat
pour le climat à l'éducation la
solidarité l'égalité la fraternité la
liberté partout des initiatives
citoyennes voient le jour et je voudrais
ici les remercier pour leur résilience
et leur abnégation ce sont elles qui
maintiennent la flamme républicaine
c'est à nous de porter ceci ce sursaut
civique et leur nez et leur énergie au
sommet nos institutions
dans cette hémicycle nous portons tous
une part de responsabilité dans ce
furieux engrenage certains ont oublié
que le débat et le compas politique ne
sont pas synonymes de violence
l'attitude policée de nos collègues du
rassemblement national qui restent assis
ne doit pas nous faire perdre de vue que
l'extrême droite est un danger pour
notre République
je vous rappelle les mots de Baudelaire
la plus belle des Russes du diable et de
nous persuader qu'il n'existe pas mais
alors Monsieur le Ministre comment
pouvons-nous apaiser notre société et
montrer merci
[Musique]